hallo ihr Lieben Toni hier und schönen
Feiertag euch Mirko schreibt mit seiner
Hündin Moni durch die Münchner Wälder
und ich bin im Allgäu beim Wandern wir
hoffen ihr macht euch mindestens einen
genauso schönen Tag wir hören uns morgen
wieder ganz normal heute aber
Feiertagsprogramm mit einem real Upload
die Folge ist aus dem Oktober 2022 also
noch bevor wir das jetzt täglich
gesendet haben dementsprechend auch
andere Stimme und zwar die von skyumor
viel Spaß beim hören und bis morgen
[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime Doku von
Bild
[Musik]
ung sag ich mal gewesen die haben auch
ein anderes
verpassen wollen und da ist
ein tödlicher Denkzettel der wäre Maus
auch Katzen Jule genannt in einer
dunklen Oktober Nacht des Jahres 2004
das Leben kostet mein Name ist und ich
begrüße euch zu einer neuen Episode von
Tatort Deutschland
[Musik]
die unscheinbare Frau 66 Jahre alt nur
zierliche ein Meter 63 groß war einsam
und mittellos Vera marotz lebte zusammen
mit ihren geliebten Katzen zurückgezogen
in der kleinen sächsischen Gemeinde
münchwitz nahe Dresden der Rentner
Christfried Seifert dessen 2005
verstorbene Frau Helga die einzige
Kontaktperson von Vera war erinnert sich
während eines Besuchs von BILD-Reporter
Bernhard Schills an die einsame Frau
miteinander geredet und das ging auch
ganz gut aber man möchte wegschauen wenn
man mit ihr redete warum wenn es darum
wenn man so also mit ihr geredet hat ein
Ding das halbweg wenn man sie aber
angesehen hat dann ging gar nicht
Reporter Bernhard Schills und die
Bild-Zeitung Dresden berichten seit
Jahren über die Ermittlungen zum Mord
oder dem Totschlag von Vera Maros die
Sammlung an Artikeln über Verbrechen
füllt einen dicken Ordner im Dresdner
Redaktionsbüro Bernhard Schills schiebt
die randlose Brille auf der Nase zurecht
und blättert durch die Seiten er der
ganze Fall ist halt so emotional weil
ich hier eine ältere Dame die ganz
allein auf der Welt war und eigentlich
sich nur um ihren eigenen Kram gekümmert
hat zum Opfer von einer Gruppe von
Schlägern geworden ist es gibt
eigentlich niemanden der hier für
Gerechtigkeit kämpft oder Gerechtigkeit
fordert Münchens eine kleine Gemeinde
bei Riesa unweit von Dresden ist
beschaulich und man lebt hier an der
Elbe nach dem Motto leben arbeiten und
Erholen in München Fritz in einer
ehemaligen DDR Plattenbausiedlung hat
hier Vera Maros zusammen mit ihren
Katzen gewohnt klar ist Vera Maros hat
es ihr Leben lang nicht sonderlich
leicht sie wurde in diese wanzt Pommern
im heutigen Polen geboren
nach dem Krieg flüchten sie und ihre
Mutter wie Millionen andere es
verschlägt sie nach München Fritz seit
dem Tod der Mutter im Jahr 1991 lebte
Vera marots ganz allein zurückgezogen
und als Außenseiterin trotzdem kannte
sie jeder in münchwitz denn Vera Marot
sammelte alles was sie fand sie war
damals nie etwas weg es wird zu der Zeit
auch gemunkelt dass sie ein Messi sei
und Sperrmüll in ihrer Wohnung und
anderen Orten hatte
auf ihrer letzten Sammeltour durch den
Ort wurde Vera marots erschlagen mehr
als 17 Jahre sind seit ihrem gewaltsamen
Tod vergangen Reporter Bernhard Schilz
weiß noch genau wie die Fahndung ganz
klein begann am Anfang war das eine
Polizeimeldung damals im Oktober 2004 wo
man sagt er ist eine ältere Dame neben
der Landstraße gefunden worden da haben
viele gedacht ist die verunfallt war das
vielleicht Fahrerflucht und zwei Tage
später kam dann die erste Meldung die
war auch bei uns noch sehr klein es
scheint ein tragischer Unfall gewesen zu
sein aber dann ändert sich alles als die
Polizei erste Spuren auswertet damals
und auch noch heute mit dem Fall betraut
ist der erste Polizeihauptkommissar der
Dresdner Kripo Frank Haschke wir
ermitteln aktiv in diesem Mordfall denn
mord verjährt nicht der
Polizeihauptkommissar sitzt im schwarzen
Anzug vor den nebeneinander
aufgestellten ermittlungsordnern zum
Fall wäre Marx
er fährt sich mit der Hand durch das
kurze graue Haar dann betrachtet der
nachdenklich die sich auf mehreren Meter
aneinanderreihenden Akten
frankreichske erinnert sich wie seine
Kollegen das Opfer auf einer kleinen
verbindungstrasse zwischen Nünchritz und
dem Ort krödel fanden die Situation
stellte sich folgendermaßen da dass die
Frau Vera Moritz zurück links auf dem
Straßenrand lag die Spurenlage war
extrem
umfangreich was erst wie ein Unfall
aussieht und nur eine kurze
Polizeimeldung wert ist wird schnell zu
einem Verbrechen zum Mord oder Totschlag
denn die Ermittler rekonstruieren in der
Nacht vom 19 auf den 20 oktober 2004
wird Vera marots unweit ihres Hauses
brutal getötet wahrscheinlich wird sie
mit Tritten und einem stumpfen
Gegenstand mal trittiert bis sie stirbt
ihr Gesicht ist völlig entstellt
Polizeihauptkommissar Haschke ist noch
heute entsetzt über Zitat extremst
brutal weil wenn man das vergleicht wie
sie auf dem feindungsfoto aussieht und
wie sie hier in der Sektion dann zu
sehen ist dann merkt man schon welche
körperliche Gewalt dahinter die Frau
dazu zuzurichten wer hat Vera Marus die
66-Jährige katzenjule auf eine Straße am
Ortsrand von Nünchritz getötet bis heute
hat die Polizei den oder die Täter nicht
gefasst aber es gibt Anhaltspunkte und
Verdachtsmomente denn in jener Oktober
Nacht geschehen noch mehr Dinge in dem
kleinen sächsischen Dorf
Bildreporter Bernhard Schilz ist erneut
nach Nünchritz gereist um den letzten
verbliebenen bekannten von Vera Marus zu
treffen und sich vor Ort noch mal an
eigenes Bild zu machen noch heute
besucht Christ Fried Seifert häufig das
Grab der Ermordeten Katzenliebhaberin
und das obwohl der nicht mehr so gut zu
Fuß ist hier erinnern ein schlichtes
steinernes Kreuz und eine Katze aus Ton
an Vera Maros Christfried Seifert fragt
sich bis heute wer hat sie getötet das
ist so eine Alster gewesen die haben
auch ein anderes Wort noch Schaden
gestiftet ich vermute man hat ihr einen
Einzel verpassen wollt und da ist
mit Halbstarken meinte Rentner
Jugendliche aus dem Umland die auf Suche
nach Spaß und vielleicht etwas
Nervenkitzel mit Alkohol und Zigaretten
durch die gegenstromen
an sich nichts schlimmes aber in dieser
Nacht verhängnisvoll denn die Stimmung
bei den Jugendlichen ist aggressiv
einige Anwohner melden noch in der Nacht
Ruhestörungen und Sachbeschädigungen bei
der Polizei das waren zum einen eine
zertrümmerte Frontscheibe eines Pkw Golf
dann wurde ein Stein in eine Scheibe
geworfen des Weiteren haben wir
festgestellt dass ein Seitenspiegel von
allen vier Panda
abgetreten wurden die Polizei vermutet
damals dass es sich um eine Gruppe von
bis zu fünf jungen Leuten handelt alle
im Alter ab ca 15 Jahren in der grödeler
Straße fanden die Jugendlichen dann
einen großen Kürbis diesen warfen sie in
die heruntergelassene Jalousie eines
Hauses an der Straße der Krach weckte
natürlich den Bewohner des Hauses er
ruft damals gleich die Polizei
gegen 1:45 Uhr von dieser
Sachbeschädigung informierte
kontrolliert in der Folge auch sein Haus
auf weitere Beschädigungen und er konnte
dabei veramarotz beobachten wie sie an
seinem Haus Vorbeigehen wir gehen davon
aus dass er der letzte Zeuge war der
wäre maraths Leben gesehen hat Rückschau
die Katzenfreundin ist also mitten in
der Nacht mit ihrem Handwagen in der
Gegend unterwegs nicht ungewöhnlich wäre
meidet die Menschen nachts fühlt sie
sich unbeobachtet und sicher
Vera Maros bringt wie immer Sperrmüll
und andere Gegenstände in ihr Lager das
ist ein scheunenverschlag in einem
winzigen ehemaligen Rittergut am
Ortsrand von Nünchritz dort wohnt damals
wie heute der Rentner Günther wie
schorke der wird zwar manchmal nachts
aus dem Schlaf gerissen wenn Vera marotz
mit ihrem Handwagen und scheppernden
Blechteilen auf das Rittergut kommt aber
die beiden haben sich abgesprochen und
so ist es für den 70-Jährigen in Ordnung
später finden Ermittler in dem
scheunenverschlag recht gut geordnete
Möbel und viele kleine Gegenstände keine
zwei Kilometer sind dieser Lagerraum und
ihre Wohnung mit den Katzen voneinander
entfernt Vera marotz war schon fast am
Ziel zwei dreihundert Meter weiter von
Tatort entfernt ist das alte Rittergut
wo sie ihre Sachen in einem Raum
unterbringen wollte
Bildreporter Bernhard Schills steht im
eisigen frühjahrswind auf der feuchten
Straße die zu dem kleinen Rittergut
führt wir sind hier auf der trödeler
Straße genau zwischen Nünchritz und
Gründel hier ist tagsüber nicht viel los
nachts noch viel weniger
am 20 oktober 2004 wurde genau hier Vera
Maros ermordet
sie wurde brutal misshandelt betreten
Schlägen gegen Körper und Kopf das hat
die Obduktion später ergeben 2004
titelte Bild nach dem klar ist dass sie
sich nicht um einen Unfall handeln kann
Katzenmutter getötet Mordkommission
ermittelt Kopfgeld Mörder gesucht für
5000 €. helfen Sie mit den Mörder von
Vera marots zu finden die Polizei hat
eigentlich gedacht na ja so eine
parodierende Schlägertruppe findet man
recht schnell da gibt's irgendwo eine
fingerspur so ein Schläger den findet
man doch und sie haben sehr schnell
gemerkt es gibt keine Spur zum Täter die
sächsische Polizei sie 2004 auch sofort
den Zusammenhang zwischen den
Sachbeschädigungen und dem Mord am
Straßenrand wäre Marus hatte die
Jugendlichen zufällig beim randalieren
mit dem Kürbis vor dem Haus beobachtet
war dass ihr Verhängnis ist
möglicherweise hat eine Person oder
mehrere Personen erkannt und deshalb
wurde sie dann auch angegriffen und in
der Folge auch tödlich verletzt wir
gehen davon aus dass diese
Personengruppe wäre Moritz begegnet ist
und höchstwahrscheinlich auch die Täter
sind aber weshalb wird aus einer
mutmaßlich zufälligen Begegnung ein
brutaler Gewaltexzess wollten die
Randalierer unerkannt bleiben und so
verhindern dass wäre Maroc sie verrät
und sie Probleme zu Hause in der Schule
oder auf der Arbeit bekommen als die
Polizei der Anzeige wegen
Sachbeschädigung nachgehen will und nach
München fährt kommen die Beamten
zufällig an der Straße zum kleinen
Rittergut vorbei die Beamten machen den
grausamen Fund für Vera Marus kommt jede
Hilfe zu spät bis heute hat die Polizei
keine Ahnung wer für den grausam Mord an
Vera marots verantwortlich ist Fakt ist
die Tatzeit konnte auf 1:45 Uhr bis 2:15
Uhr eingeschränkt werden und genau eine
halbe Stunde zuvor ist Vera marotz hier
auf dieser Straße das letzte Mal Leben
gesehen worden
mit ihrem Handkarren in Richtung Grödel
unterwegs war die Ermittler machen ihren
Job gut finden aber am Tatort keine
knallharten Hinweise auf die Täter erst
bei der Obduktion von vereras Leiche
machen Sie eine erste
erfolgsversprechende Entdeckung unter
den Fingernägeln des Opfers finden sich
DNA-Spuren vor ihrem Tod muss sie also
jemanden festgehalten oder verzweifelt
versucht haben sich zu wehren mittels
dieser gesicherten DNA-Spur hoffte die
Polizei nun den oder die Täter zu
überführen die den ausspuren wurden zum
Teil an der Bekleidung von Vera Mauritz
gesichert und auch unter den
Fingernägeln der Leiche von Vera Moritz
diese den Spuren unter den Fingernägeln
bezog sich auf eine weibliche Person es
kam wieder Bewegung in die Ermittlung
die fahrender waren motiviert hatte
vielleicht eine Frau Vera marots auf dem
Gewissen das hätte den Täterkreis
halbiert
aber war die Frau vielleicht nur eine
Mitläuferin hatte sie bei der Gewalttat
nur zugesehen wenn ja wie kann sie bis
heute mit den schrecklichen Bildern von
der wehrlosen Frau leben
die Polizei ermittelt nun fieberhaft sie
suchte jetzt nach einer Frau als
Nünchritz und ernähren Umgebung im Jahr
2005 werden Frauen im Alter zwischen 15
und 40 Jahren aus münchwitz und Umgebung
gebeten eine Speichelprobe abzugeben man
will einen großen Vergleichstest
vornehmen allerdings ist der freiwillig
Carmen Ermittler Frank Haschke und die
Polizei mit dieser Reihenuntersuchung
der gesuchten Frau auf die Spur in der
Summe wurden dann insgesamt etwa 2500
weibliche Personen dem Test unterzogen
bisher konnten wir keine positive
Zuordnung zu diesen Spuren vornehmen ein
riesiger Aufwand für nichts der Fall
wäre Marus wird zum Cold Case
als Cold Case wird so ein Fall meistens
nach hinten geschoben der neue
dringendere Fälle warten darauf gelöst
zu werden und hinzu kam niemand aus der
Öffentlichkeit machte Druck denn Vera
Maros hatte niemanden außer ihren Katzen
ja könnten keine Familie von Vera Moritz
ausfindig machen die quasi die
Forderungen an die Polizei stellt diese
Verbrechen aufzuklären deswegen ist es
für uns ein Ansporn von uns heraus diese
Tat aufzuklären um der Gerechtigkeit
dann zu genüge zu tun 2005 startet die
Polizei Dresden daher einen
ungewöhnlichen öffentlichen Aufruf um
das Mädchen oder die junge Frau zu
DNA-Spur zu finden Frank Haschke bitte
zusammen mit der Bild-Zeitung die Eltern
oder Personen die diese junge Frau
kennen könnten sich zu melden
haben sie im Oktober 2004 bei ihrer
Tochter ihrem Lehrling ihrer bekannten
Kratzspuren gesehen für die sie keine
Erklärung hatte vielleicht war die junge
Frau selbst schockiert darüber was ihre
Begleiter Taten helfen sie die
Ermittlungen zu verkürzen ich appelliere
an ihr Gewissen und die Strategie von
Polizeihauptkommissar Frank Haschke
scheint aufzugehen in den letzten Jahren
erreichten uns zahlreiche Hinweise wir
haben diese entsprechend unserer
Spurenlage auch verglichen wir könnten
aber keine weiteren Verdachtsmomente
gegen bestimmte Personen erwirken
Bildreporter Bernhards hat einen
Verdacht vielleicht kennen die Münchner
die Frau deren DNA sich unter den
Fingernägeln der Getöteten befand und
wollen dieses Wissen einfach verdrängen
oder ignorieren gibt es Menschen die
wissen wer dabei war und sagen sich naja
es hatte halt eine alte Frau getroffen
die hatte keine Familie um die hat keine
getrauert die hatte nichts also kein
Grund
für ein Leben lang ins Gefängnis zu
gehen also behalte ich mein Wissen für
mich und auch der Polizist vermutet dass
es Menschen geben muss die seit mehr als
17 Jahren schweigen wir können nicht in
die Köpfe der Täter reinschauen wir
können aber davon ausgehen dass diese
Täter mit dieser Schuld leben müssen und
möglicherweise
irgendwann
diese Belastung nicht mehr aushalten und
sich dann offenbaren auf
diesen passen wir hinarbeiten und
deswegen appellieren wir immer an die
Bevölkerung und weitere Hinweise zu
geben
dass wir diese Tat aufklären können
der Bildreporter sitzt wieder in der
Küche des Rentners Christ Fried Seifert
in München Fritz der Kaffee dampft auf
dem Tisch was sehen Sie wie kann das
sein dass das Ganze seit 17 Jahren nicht
aufgeklärt ist es gibt ein Gericht dass
derjenige der hier den täglich sagen
versetzt hat sich vom Suchergebnisse
woher kommt dieses Gericht
das kann ich im Ursprung auch nicht
sagen vielleicht haben die Täterin der
Täter oder die Gruppe solchen Gerüchte
die Welt gesetzt um von sich abzulenken
oder hat sich der Haupttäter umgebracht
weil er oder sie ein schlechtes Gewissen
hatte
schweigen die möglichen Mitesser deshalb
hartnäckig
bestätigen will das niemand gegen Tote
wird nicht ermittelt
trinkt seinen Kaffee aus er muss zurück
in die Redaktion und verabschiedet sich
als er mit dem Auto an dem winzigen
Rittergut vorbeikommt sieht er den
Rentner Günther wie tschorke vor der
Scheune auf einer alten Bratpfanne
herumschlagen auf dem gut leben heute
noch viele Katzen Günter sagt dass es
alles wäre es Katzen und deren
Nachkommen sind heute sind sie halb wild
aber wenn er die Bratpfanne schlägt
kommen sie alle angelaufen denn dann
gibt es Futter die Katzen sind alles was
von Vera Maritz geblieben ist
die Fahndung der Mordkommission Dresden
jedoch geht weiter wenn sie in der Nacht
vom 19 zum 20 oktober 2004 Personen
Personengruppen gesehen gehört haben die
mit dieser Tat mit den Sachbeschädigung
in Verbindung gebracht werden kann dann
wenden Sie sich an die Polizei wir
suchen weiterhin diese weibliche Person
die die Spuren an mehrere Maurer als
verursacht hat wie appellieren an diese
Person sich zu offenbaren
beziehungsweise wir appellieren an
Personen die diese Person kennen der
Polizei Hinweise zu geben so dass wir
auch diese Straftat aufklären können
wenn ihr also Hinweise habt bitte meldet
euch diese nimmt auch jede
Polizeidienststelle und die Polizei
Direktion Dresden vertraulich entgegen
helft mit den grausamen mortern Vera
marrotz aufzuklären ich danke euch fürs
zuhören und dass ihr wieder dabei wart
bei Tatort Deutschland bis zum nächsten
mal euer Sky du
Tatort Deutschland ist eine Produktion
aus den Wake world Studios
Projektleitung Simone terbrack
Produktion Fabian Scheffler Drehbuch
Lutz Neumann Redaktion Bild Bernhard
Schulz und Stefan netzebald